هناك
فرصة ألا تنجو من هذه الحرب ، فقد أوضح
الروس
أنهم
يعتبرونك نازيًا
وما إلى ذلك ، كل هذا هراء
كيف تريد أن يتذكرك الشعب الأوكراني
كيف
تريد أن يتذكرك ابنك وابنتك
كإنسان  لكوني أحب الحياة إلى
أقصى حد وأحب عائلته وأحب
وطنه الأم
بالتأكيد ليس بطلاً ،
أريد أن يأخذني الناس
لأنني إنسان عادي ألهمت الكثير من
الناس بما في ذلك ليس فقط هنا في
أوكرانيا ولكن في جميع أنحاء
العالم  يلهمك من هم أبطالك
الذين تتطلع إلى إلهام قصتهم
خلال الأيام المظلمة هنا
فقط الأشخاص الذين
أعتقد أن شعبنا حقيقي
وفريد ​​من نوعه
ولا يمكنني تحمل أن أكون أسوأ
منهم
عندما أشعر في لحظات معينة بأنني
جميعًا  هذا أمر خطير ،
أتفهم أن كل البقية منا
يمرون
بهذا وهذا كل شيء
والأهم هو الطريقة التي
ينظر بها أطفالي إلي
عليهم أن يفخروا بي ،
هذا هو أهم
شيء أفعله.  كل شيء لهذا ماذا
تقول للناس سواء في أوكرانيا أو
في أي مكان آخر في العالم الذين يقولون
فقط أعط بوتين دونباس فقط أعط
بوتين
شرق أوكرانيا توقف عن إراقة الدماء ،
دعه يمتلك المنطقة ماذا
ستكون رسالتك عن ذلك
في التاريخ الذي يمتد لقرون  في أوكرانيا ،
هناك قصة أن أوكرانيا
قد استولت على بعض الأراضي أو تحتاج إلى
التخلي عن بعض الأراضي ،
لذلك
نتخلى عن منطقتنا ،
فإن أوكرانيا ستفوز في هذه الحرب ، نعم
بالطبع
،
وهل ألهمت الكثير من الناس
بما في ذلك ليس فقط  هنا في أوكرانيا ولكن في
جميع أنحاء العالم
من يلهمك من هم أبطالك
الذين تتطلع إلى الإلهام قصتهم
خلال الأيام المظلمة هنا
فقط الأشخاص الذين
أعتقد أن شعبنا حقيقي
وفريد ​​من نوعه ولا يمكنني تحمل أن أكون
أسوأ منهم
عندما  في لحظات معينة أشعر أن
كل هذا خطير ،
أفهم أن البقية منا
يمرون بهذا بالإضافة إلى
ما أفعله كل شيء من أجل هذا
أنت